dans des limites à tout le monde le fait
mais là messieurs
quant à libramont
aussi
égalisant
je vais chanter il ya un truc et je
comprends pas peut-être vous vexer en
disant ça mais au moins c'est sincère
quand je vous vois là vous êtes du
niveau de christina aguilera jennifer
lopez pourquoi vous n'êtes pas autant de
succès que ces gonzesses
c'est pas moi qui décide si quand même
si vous prenez c'est un peu la légère
non je sais pas avec un peu de
désinvolture pour m'amuser star
planétaire je veux qui fait au début
quand j'ai commencé je voulais être la
star du monde et ça me tellement rien
dire que voilà je suis content que
j'écris des chansons les gens les
achètent les écoutes dans le reste c'est
manu bien habillés et bien non c'est
parfait il exprime plus d'un et
merveilleux propos oui alors c'est très
voilà trois fois cette touche un peu là
nattawut
faire des trucs en même temps bon gens
vous l'avez vu comme nogent
mais un fait qui peut tout fait vrai on
dirait du feydeau tout fait dites moi
alors sérieusement maintenant est ce que
vous vous masturbez beaucoup c'était sûr
qu'ils avaient une valeur d'un temps de
les tester de manière raisonnable et ça
vous arrive quand même étude le avez
vous comme mais oui la samarie bien sûr
laurent la libération je veux dire en ce
moment je me dégoûte
je me touchent même pas
les voix
dès lors ce single il ya un titre inédit
qui s'appelle give me more donne moi
plus là on n'en sort pas je suis désolé
jantes vous vous exposez à tout ça mais
c'est vrai que alors